welcome everyone thank you for joining
this afternoon at uh
google's
csg
central st giles i thought it was
customer service group something like
that central st giles um
i'm going to speaking today about
counting the cost of the not so lean
enterprise
it's a bit of a mouthful
um
sorry there's just a slide about myself
i'm graham's able i head up our devops
practice with indivo team uk
but i prefer this title storage is cheap
how many people have heard this
expression storage is cheap and we've
just had a nice
talk on on storage and um you know how
we store lots and lots of data and data
marks and data warehouses
so we all think storage is cheap and
because it's cheap we don't think about
it really
but i will argue today that we should be
thinking about it
data centers are currently responsible
for about 3.6 of our global
carbon emissions
that number is going to grow as we build
more and more data centers and as other
sectors within our economy
decarbonize so lots of other sectors are
working very hard at decarbonizing as is
the iit sector but because data centers
are growing so so quickly we are going
to be
producing more and more of the world's
carbon in the future
so this is
uh it's an ethical issue
the uh ecological impacts of computation
in the cloud it's an environmental issue
we look at this
this headline at the bottom
air travel is currently responsible for
two percent of global emissions
so almost half of that of data centers
and yet it's very much in the spotlight
now about
reducing air travel etc so
we can be sure that emissions associated
with storage
are going to become an increasingly hot
topic in the future
this is a headline from a couple of
months ago the security and exchange
commission
in america wants all public companies to
be reporting on their carbon emissions
this is the direction of travel globally
it's not only in america it's not only
public companies we are all increasingly
going to have to re report on our carbon
emissions
so making door making data storage
efficient it's not a nice to have
it's really essential if we want to play
our part in getting to net zero in the
future um this and this by the way this
reporting is is not only you may have
heard of scope 1 and scope 2 and a scope
3 emissions
scope 3 emissions are the hardest ones
to track and the ones where most of our
carbon is being emitted so
more and more companies have upped into
up till now been very good at reporting
scope 1 and scope 2 emissions but now
we're going to be up having to report on
scope 3 as well
and the companies that do best in
reducing their carbon emissions are the
ones that are going to be most
successful in the future
more and more of our consumers are going
to be asking us how much carbon do we
produce in in when we go about our
business so they're going to win rep
they're going to win
reputationally because of public cares
they're going to win also in terms of
saving money
and being more efficient
okay so um
i've been working in it for over 30
years
i have to admit
and one of the things that's disturbed
me most
in my time in it is how much waste there
is in it
and and this problem doesn't seem to be
getting better as we get more and more
complexes or as organizations get get
larger with increased scale
this issue of waste is getting worse
now i'm going to speak uh today i'm
going a little bit off piece by the way
i'm not going to talk about gcp
necessarily i know we're in the google
in the google building at the moment but
really i'm going to talk generally about
devops and carbon and this this issue
goes beyond any one cloud provider it's
also an on-prem issue
and specifically around devops
devops our devops pipelines are really
underpin everything we do in our it
organizations it's a platform that
affects everyone
you know you could take something like a
kubernetes platform kubernetes
affects people that are using containers
you can talk about data platforms where
we've just discussed but devops really
is pervasive across everything we do so
um poorly maintained devops engines
are they're wasteful they're costly they
are polluting um they they if they don't
perform well it's a very poor developer
experience so
um
and in fact if our devops tools are out
of date if they're not if they're not
running but
well
we'd get staff attrition people leave
they leave to go to companies that have
that do this better so it's it's about
attracting us keeping and attracting our
staff
um and ironically despite the fact that
these devops engines are important
across all rit organization
they're underfunded and understaffed
typically in large organizations
so um
yeah and one other thing so i'm going to
use this image of a physical data
warehouse
and compare it to
what we do in the devops world in in
terms of storing things in virtual
warehouses so what do we store in these
virtual warehouses for devops
um we store things like wiki pages jira
projects
code repositories
ci cd pipelines artifacts
telemetry all this is really the kind of
pure devops stuff that comes out of our
devops tool chains
but also more broadly
cloud resources
applications themselves
processes how you know um
automated workflow management tooling
etc etc
so
the commonality with all of these uh
virtual warehouses that store our
virtual devops stuff
is it's very easy to get stuff into
these warehouses
and it's very very hard once it's in
these warehouse to get it out almost
impossible in fact so why is it
impossible
a lot of companies specifically
financial services companies
have very strict data retention policies
so once data is in a warehouse it has to
stay there for at least seven years it
cannot be removed to try and get it
removed is is layers and layers of
bureaucracy if you want to delete
something in a production system
after two three four years we start to
lose track of what's important in these
stores so it's often the people that
create these jira projects or these code
repositories then they you know after
four years they've left the company
their name is still attached to this
stuff no one knows what to do with it is
it important is it in use we don't know
so if in doubt we leave it there there's
a there's a fear factor
if we don't know best not to touch it
and then
really importantly is a lot of this data
is missing the tags and labels that can
tell us what this data is and i'm going
to get back to that because that's a
very important topic
right so as a consequence because it's
easy to get stuff in and hard to put it
out these stores get bigger and bigger
and bigger
until they look like the virtual
equivalent of this
um
so this is a mess okay so if you take
this this concept of a warehouse
if you think about an ikea warehouse and
you go shopping to ikea and you you look
through all their showrooms and then you
go downstairs to the floor below and you
have these big warehouses with aisles
and aisles of cardboard boxes can you
imagine if half of those boxes didn't
have labels on them
you wouldn't have a viable business
walking around ikea trying to find stuff
and there's no labels on it and yet we
do exactly that in the virtual world we
store stuff in these in these
repositories in jira systems
um in telemetry systems and we don't
label it so we don't actually even know
what it is or sometimes we'll have you
can see some pictures on here someone
will scribble some writing on a box and
that means something to them and to no
one else and we do exactly that
in uh in our code repositories we'll
stir some code and we'll say my my cool
project no one else no one knows if that
project is is it production if it's not
in production can we delete it we don't
know so um
so
all so much of what we're storing really
has no function it just sits there
forever and ever it sits on the top
shelf
no one ever looks at it and often these
devops tools
the task of managing these tools
particularly legacy tools we hand off to
protect potentially a lonely contractor
so you've got one person who's in charge
of this legacy git repository
there's no way that they have time to go
through and look at the top shelves and
start cleaning this stuff up they're
just dealing with
the day-to-day noise of running these
systems
or sometimes will even worse will
outsource it to a third party and that
third party will have no
incentive or no interest to tidy this
stuff up they're just charged to manage
it and keep it going
now the biggest difference between this
warehouse and a virtual warehouse where
we're storing all kinds of crap is in
the virtual warehouse it's using
electricity 24 hours a day 7 days a week
365 days a year so it's consuming
lots and lots of power which is
contributing to this 3.6 percent of our
global carbon emissions
so what do we do when we end what would
what do we do when we have a situation
situation like this and yeah i was going
to mention an anecdote
with with one of our clients we're
working with they have a git repository
it's
now probably 10 years old it's a get lab
repository it's probably five major
versions out of date
one contractor is supporting it
we tried to upgrade it to the latest
version of git lab so we tried to do
this in a pre-production environment it
took one week to upgrade the system
because it was so many versions out of
date because there was so much stuff in
there so
essentially they said
you know can you imagine sending an
email to your developer community and
saying
really sorry guys but uh we're going to
take down our git system for a week you
can't chicken in any code
no one is ever going to do that it's too
embarrassing you'd probably lose your
job so what do we do we just say oh well
let's buy a new instance and so we end
up and we go and buy a new instance and
we end up with a new repository and then
we have a massive migration project to
get to put the mess into the new the new
warehouse and believe it or not this is
how this is happening right now with
this particular client they've got all
this stuff so they're now gonna they're
now gonna migrate the 50 000 projects
into their brand new nice warehouse
because they don't know what all these
things do so if in doubt just migrate it
they'll write really nice automated
migration scripts and they'll migrate
all mess into the new into the new
system
so if you if you take some of these
tools you know we've got um
we've got confidence spaces where up to
80 of the con of the data is out of date
we've got jira projects or jira jira
systems
with
lots and lots of dead projects or empty
projects or people spin up a jira
project then they run it for two months
and it gets canned and then that jira
project stays there forever and ever or
or we've got some from five six years
ago where the owners are long gone no
one knows what to do with it so they
leave it there
we've got thousands of customized custom
fields which make
which make this jira system itself
slower more cumbersome providing a poor
experience
these systems then become hard to
maintain hard to upgrade
you get poor poor developer experience
as i mentioned so what do we what do we
do well let's get a new jira instance
um code repositories like gitlab github
uh perforce previously
as i mentioned the one particular
instance that i've been working on
recently has 50 000 repositories in it
there's hello world project or test
projects from five years ago
um you'll get proof of concept projects
people do they create a proof of concept
they store it they they forget about it
they leave the company and it just sits
there for at least seven years probably
probably longer
all adding up to this poor uh poor
developer experience and poor poor
tooling
a colleague
current uh that i've i talked to
recently worked with a midlands utility
lifting and shifting uh 200 applications
into the cloud
as they went through this exercise they
realized that 80 of those 200
applications were not even used we're
not needed they've been superseded they
were obsolete so
40
of their
running applications
were essentially not used 40
um
i should have changed that logo through
to aws but
sorry to gcp but this was an aws issue
um
where we've recently been working with
another client
they had a whole development system that
customers could use
on aws to create prototypes and create
test projects
they came to us because their costs were
exploding because it was insecure
and we spent six months two people six
months on this and we cut their cloud
bills by 80 percent
just by turning off turning off stuff
that was no longer needed no longer used
we worked with another client they have
over a thousand container platforms
because there's no governance around how
you create a container platform so every
team just spins up their own and spins
up their own and all of a sudden you've
got a thousand different container
platforms
uh this is a another example i want to
talk about uh in terms of artifact
repositories where we store our binary
artifacts our code libraries
this is these are two different banks
that i've been involved with
and with their artifact repositories
the one on the left is twice as big in
bank in terms of developer community
applications as the one on the right
and yet their artifact repository is one
tenth the size so i worked on this on
this artifact repository and it was
already bloated and we did a lot of work
reorganizing it putting controls and
guard rails around how we use this
we got it down to seven terabytes and
given more time we could probably have
shrunk that in half again or certainly
by a couple more terabytes we still we
knew there was still a lot of junk in
there uh that hadn't been cleaned up
you know you take the instance on the
right
there is no there's no governance in
that in that instance people just dump
stuff in there and it never gets cleaned
up so you've got for example
uh and backups of entire websites on a
daily basis being backed up into this
repository for years and years and then
all of a sudden they stop so let's say
there's a a a major website they're
backing it up every day and in 2021 they
start backing it up and no one knows why
but the backs of backups have stopped so
do we still need to keep those backups
do we just keep them there forever do we
need to keep everyday backups or can we
cut them down to one a month
we don't know so we just they're all
they're all still there
um
we've got continuous build servers
jenkins servers or git lab
build build servers
pumping out artifacts so because we have
these this lovely continuous build and
continuous deploy systems we have things
continually deploying artifacts into
these repositories
sometimes every five minutes every 10
minutes
and there's no governance to clean this
stuff up so this just grows and grows
and grows until it's 70 terabytes in
size
and then it becomes almost unupgradable
because it's so big and so so cumbersome
um so we're you know we're not talking
about sort of five ten percent
difference in the way you can improve
your storage we're talking about a
magnitude of difference or ninety
percent better more efficient ways of
storing data
so uh what do we do as i've said
sorry what do we do we you know we
typically just buy a new instance and
then migrate all this stuff over
um
but really what should we do
is
make it harder for that data to get into
our systems
when i say make it harder so i don't
mean make it harder to create a jira
project or make it harder to create a
code repository this stuff is typically
already too hard so if you take creating
a jira project for example
it's about a five minute exercise if
you're a jira admin to create a jira
project but if you're in most large
enterprises that five minute exercise
probably takes two days or sometimes a
week to get a jira project because you
don't have admin rights so you've got to
fill out forms and create requests that
go to a central team and they do it for
you and this five minute exercise takes
an elapsed time of two days or so so i'm
not suggesting make it harder to create
the stuff in fact we should make it
easier to create jira projects and and
code repositories
and confluence spaces etc
but make it harder for this stuff to
stick so make it harder for it to
persist
and how do we do that well we can have
ring fence sandboxes we can say if
you're creating proof of concepts or
hello world projects great put them in
the sandbox knowing that we're going to
delete all the stuff within six months
so so you can start creating start start
your sandbox today you don't have to
fill in any forms
start today but put it in the sandbox
and if you want to move it to the next
stage then you can start filling out the
forms for a longer term life span but
you can create the stuff today we'll
clean it up for you
stuff
arguably if your code repository or your
jira project or your artifacts do not
have tags they should be ripe for
deletion if something doesn't have a tag
you should delete it everything you
store in these systems should be tagged
either with an app by an application
name or a product code or a team
certainly not an individual individuals
come and go there's no point tagging
stuff with an individual's name because
by the time you you wanna you have to
deal with it they're probably left so
you should be tagging it by a product
code or a or an application code
and then you can get much you can get
really good information around who's
using all of our storage if half the
stuff in your code repository is tagged
with equity say if you're in a bank then
you can go to the equities department
and say you should be paying for half of
this storage because it's all it's all
your stuff
so tag by tagging things it makes it
much easier to manage what's in there
and who and what you can do about it
and then i mentioned the guard rails as
well put guard rails in if they if a
jira project hasn't been touched for a
year
send the team an email send a second
email send a third email reminder if no
one does anything about it then you can
archive it or delete it so
make it harder for data to stick
and make it easier to delete stuff which
goes hand in hand so if things aren't
tagged
delete them if things haven't been
touched for a year or two years and you
cannot delete them put them in a deep
archive have automated cleanup policies
so
when you're
when we talk about being greener and we
talk about being more efficient and
reducing our carbon emissions and
getting to net zero
there's a lot of talk about
uh we can dow you know
all the cloud vendors will give you
great tools to downgrade your your
your compute instances if they're if
they're not utilized properly or move
your storage to lower your lower tiered
storage classes you can save five
percent here or save 10 here by by using
your infrastructure more efficiently
more efficiently i would say a lot of
that is just dancing around the edges
we're talking we've shown examples here
where we're talking about 90 savings or
40 savings by you by doing a better job
of understanding what we're storing
so this and and this these are
essentially easy easier problems to
solve and will give us a much much
bigger bang for our buck in terms of
saving costs and reducing emissions
so we want to get to a place where we
have storage like this no matter how big
or how small
we everything is labeled properly
everything you can see here is a bar has
a barcode in it we should be able to
scan the stuff and know exactly what it
is know exactly who owns it know exactly
how long it's been there and doesn't
need to stay there or can we get rid of
it
so
storage is cheap
smarter storage which in my book means
less storage
is cheaper
more productive
provides a better user experience
and most importantly is less polluting
that's my talk thank you very much
[Applause]
any questions
i'm curious
is there much on data dupe that you
find so hashing and finding identicals
um
in in data stores because
from experience that tends to be a
really big piece of of the storage um
and i'm wondering if there's an
automated way that you've got to to do
to yeah yeah yeah um
it's a good point um
i you know i think that would be part of
our automation task is you can automate
a lot of that stuff as well
i don't i don't mention that
specifically or i haven't mentioned that
specifically in this talk but very much
so it is it's another way of of using
data badly yeah
uh thank you for your presentation um
you started off the presentation with uh
mentioning some of the carbon footprint
numbers and percentages
now let's imagine that we all become
very aware and responsible storage
citizens
how much of that carbon footprint
number can shrink by becoming
responsible
that's a very good question too dennis
and i certainly don't have the answer to
that and you know and
i mean you could just talk about cat
photos probably and
and there's probably more more storage
with cat photos than a lot of this
devops stuff so
how big those numbers are i don't know
but i i think
what i do know is that there are vast
amounts of waste
and we need to be able to tackle that
waste in an automated efficient manner
and we can do our bit
to you know to to to help solve this
problem
and also to provide much better uh
developer experience because
i see so many developers struggling with
their tools jira you know um sorry i'm
going a little bit off piece with this
with this answer but uh
we thought you know i've talked to some
jira administrators and with one of our
clients too where everyone is
complaining that jira is too slow
and and if developers you know if it
takes one second to load a page
it's you can kind of live with it it
takes a second it should take a tenth of
a second
but if you add up that one second times
every time you load a page times every
developer and everyone that uses jira in
your company you can come up with very
significant numbers so
so i think
i you know how much we can save i don't
really know but i i do know that
doing our bit will will give you lots of
other benefits as well
um
so i have a question you mentioned um
migrating old repositories to
an instance in the cloud how far would
that go to tidying up the data
from moving on prem to cloud yeah or
well
um yes so
just the migration itself yeah um
some companies actually the one example
i use
where they're lifting and shifting
applications
as they do that they kind of
it you've got to you've got to be able
to look into the data and what because
what happens is most of the time we get
these big warehouses and no one ever
really looks at them but it's when you
do that lifted shift people start
opening up those boxes on the top shelf
and saying oh well what's actually in
here it's a bit like cleaning out your
loft at home you know you have all these
boxes in there for years and years and
no one ever looks at them and then
finally when you're moving house you've
got to open up the box and say oh here's
a bunch of you know
christmas toys from when the kids were
small we don't need them anymore we can
give them the charity and as you move
your you know you move house you clean
up a lot of the stuff that's been in
boxes and so i think it's that exercise
of my grading which forces a company to
say oh what's inside what what are we
storing here but until you do that it
just sits there because no one's no
one's got the time or or
desire to consume it was like the whole
team and the whole company doing that
rather than
um just like an individual looking at
the yeah
and some individuals are conscientious
and they'll clean up their little part
of the big thing but most of it is right
yeah because at my company we do have um
an old jquery repository that hasn't
been touched in
four to seven years and i think we do
need to work on that
i've seen in these code repositories
code repos that are 15 20 years old and
have not had a check-in for 15 years and
you kind of think well
is you know is it still in production i
don't you know who knows
i don't know right
yeah i think that's everything
hi thanks for the presentation um so i'm
from google and so i just want to say
two things and and one question so the
first thing is uh for those of you who
are not aware
google right now is
carbon neutral
and our goal is to be uh to run on
carbon free energy 24 7 in all our data
centers by 2030. so if you want to know
more about it um yeah we have a specific
i know
google is leading the way a lot of this
so and the second comment is actually
about our cloud
google cloud summit sustainability
summit in june 28th so we'll be great if
you can join so we will be sharing
our journey and and the things that
we're doing on that area now the
question is uh so from uh your
perspective and as a
cloud service provider what can we do
best or or better to in order to to help
on this journey
i mean obviously
obviously a lot of this has to be
automated you know we can't you know if
you take the example of an ikea
warehouse if you have two or three
humans going through box by box it will
take weeks and weeks
for them to clean this stuff up so
you've got to have the automated
guardrails and
so we have done this with some of our
clients where
it's very simple stuff like
as i mentioned if a jira project doesn't
get used for one for one year
if there's no check-ins for one year
whether it's a code repository or an
artifact uh
repository etc if it's not used for one
year
you can send emails to the owners or you
know have some kind of automated process
saying we will you know and you i'm sure
you get this with emails we will delete
this after six weeks we will delete this
after four weeks if we don't hear from
you etc and you and then if you don't
hear from anyone you put it in deep
storage or deep archive or if it's if
you deem it not important
a lot of the stuff can be deleted that's
a bit trickier
question but certainly you can put it in
some some kind of deep
deep archive so we've got to deal with
this issue through automation
and it's the people setting up all these
tools in in in the case of devops
dueling
it's quite easy to do a lot of that um
but people don't think about it or
they're not you know they're they're too
busy delivering features and not
thinking about the technical debt that
they're incurring
but i think we've you know we've got to
spend more time and effort and resource
on the technical debt through automation
to help keep these tools well maintained
you're welcome
anymore
do not thank you very much